In five,
four,
three,
two.
Welcome everybody to the CBOE zones.
Join me under the Gazebo.
Would you please guys welcome to the
Gazebos zone.
I need you still understand,
okay that when I express anything here
under the Gazebo,
it's correct and true and all opinions
given forth are infallible or are uh,
indisputable and by the very nature of
themselves and possible to contradict.
That is what it means to be under the
Gazebo.
And I thank you all for joining me here
today in the correct opinion zone.
Take you to our sponsors.
Quipped stitch fix and dollar shave
club.
If you would like to share your opinion
under the Gazebo with us today,
give us a call at eight oh eight hot
mean,
give us a ring today.
We'd love to hear from you.
How are you?
Good.
There was an episode of the Prophet
where he helped a business of people who
were making,
you know,
cause that's funny.
And every time they said Gazyva I had to
giggle.
It's like I can't,
but so weird.
All of a sudden everybody's talking
about the z boats like once.
When did you ever hear,
cause you beau used in a conversation
ever.
I can't hear it.
We're not laughing now.
They literally made gazebos.
That was their company.
Yeah.
Um,
they read cool.
Good.
They were in the Gazebo zone.
Yeah they were nice cause egos.
They were not your everyday a tlc cause
he but let me tell you,
these were premium made guys.
Welcome everybody.
Thank you for joining us.
So wonderful to have you here.
I'm here joined by the illustrious a
beautiful Isla Kline,
my,
my pregnant beautiful wife by the way I
say pregnant,
beautiful wife because ever since we
found out you're pregnant and we're
always like all right,
you were still pregnant cause you
because it's like kind of uneasy of
during the first three months because
you can have a miscarriage somewhat
commonly like 10 to 15% I read.
But I just,
I think it's so amazing.
You're so cool.
I always think to myself,
they say apparently there was already a
heartbeat.
That's unbelievable.
And they say,
well,
this website we read,
they described the baby that she has as
the size of a pip,
an orange seed and orange seed,
but they called it a pip,
which I thought was really funny.
Pipsqueak little pip,
but I just think it's so amazing that ul
has,
has this little pip and sober.
I don't know.
I just,
I'm so charmed by that.
I just think it's amazing.
And you've gained a little weight.
You've been eating great.
She's super healthy.
She's radiant,
and I'm already gaining weight and let's
see how much look at this.
I just,
I'm so in love with my beautiful
pregnant wife who's got this little pit
inside of her.
We've got our first ultrasound in like
two weeks or week.
Oh wait.
Oh Shit.
Right?
Yeah.
I think it's 10 days.
I can't believe it.
It's still feels so surreal,
but yeah.
That's going to make it feel real.
Yeah,
sure.
There's your little pip.
We're trying to think of a name.
Maybe pip.
He Lazy.
Now go with your first instinct for
sure.
Let's go for it.
Uh,
at any rate,
guys,
let's get into the show.
I'm charmed to be here.
You're a,
let's get started right away with your
goof of the day.
There's a lot to get to.
Um,
under the Gazebo here today.
Now this video comes courtesy of your
boy Tom Segura.
I saw this on instagram and I had to
share it with them.
So this is a professional boxer who is
having a promoting a big fight he's
having,
and I'm this,
I'm trying to break this down for you
guys cause it's so,
it's so wild.
Okay,
let me show you the video.
So he's on a daytime television show on
some mascot comes out dressed in a
burrito and um,
I think he was meant to punch him in the
stomach cause you can see the whole
space and like hit him right here.
Hit him right here.
And this box,
this is a boxer,
a world class fighter.
He punches this fucking guy in the face
as hard as he can do it.
And you could tell that Burrito,
that Tortilla padding just isn't enough.
So let's see who is usually inside those
two.
It's totally like he's the guy,
not someone who can take a punch.
Apparently.
Apparently he broke
son of bitches jar and you see him
writhing around in pain and everyone's
kind of clowning on him.
But he,
he,
he's like trying to touch like yeah.
He's like,
dude,
I'm not okay.
Not everyone's clowning on him one more
time.
Right in the stomach
fucking thing.
Oh cool.
So I just loved that the host,
he does pat the stomach and then last
minute,
yeah,
I think it's his fault.
Really.
The host,
well I don't know if anyone speaks
Spanish.
Maybe he was like punch him here.
Definitely don't punch him.
He just,
that poor guy.
He probably had like padding,
like extra padding on the stomach and
nothing and oh my God,
this thin little tortilla layer.
So apparently he broke Shah and this guy
said on twitter,
I didn't know.
It sounds ironic,
his apology cause it kind give me a good
goal.
He said,
I sincerely apologize to the brave man
that was injured.
I have the utmost respect for him.
His party,
he's talking about the guy in the brood
is suit.
I have the utmost respect for the
burrito boy.
Uh,
his participation,
willingness and courage.
He says true hero.
If this is true,
I would personally like to invite him to
my December 1st fight.
Yeah.
You see what you're trying to give this
guy flashbacks because they have to,
where's Burrito costume?
I don't know why.
I just,
it had me in stitches,
frankly.
Uh,
he,
he tossed the beat.
He beat the salsa right out of the
brewery.
Not a Mexican joke.
A burrito joke.
Let's be clear.
I've gotten way more class and
integrity.
You can make a race related jokes about,
cause they put salsa and Burritos as
well as rice and beans and stuff like
that.
I thought that was not,
or do I need to make an apology?
Um,
here's another good one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Shannon,
your pieces here.
Okay.
Does just a goofy,
but we're just getting started here.
A lubing it up or lighten it up.
You know what I'm saying?
So this person decided to order a pizza
and they put a sign on the door that
said,
scream shannon,
your pizza is here.
Do not ring the doorbell or knock,
our grandma is sleeping upstairs cause
you know,
I have to say,
what do you think about somebody leaving
a sign on a door for pizza delivery guy
to scream?
Shannon,
your pizza's here.
No one would actually do that.
Yeah.
It's a kind of,
it's asking a lot of a pizza guy scream.
Most favor will probably not even read
the letter.
It's not about asking someone to scream.
It's kind of like,
I'm not screaming.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But this guy,
he,
he receives the note and he
reciprocates.
So what did the note say again?
It said script,
please scream.
Shannon,
your pizza's here because my grandma's
sleeping and the doorbell.
We'll rake my Nana.
So let's see how this brilliant mind
reacts to that.
And look at this guy strutting up like a
thousand pizza.
Like this guy's a pizza.
God,
if I've ever seen one,
he assesses the situation.
He strolls up with the confidence of a
thousand food buzz,
a thousand pies.
I feel like there's no sound.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's no sound.
Oh,
well that's pretty critical.
Do you have?
Oh yeah,
I got it.
I'd mix it.
Let's try it again.
Here we go.
And here we go.
So foolish maximus of approaches the
door,
pizza in hand,
the Crows,
the crows are crying and anticipation of
what's to come.
Thank you
Darren.
He screams in the faith.
Still not.
What I'm wondering is because asking a
pizza boy to shout,
I am wondering if this was his way of
being like fuck you for making me a
shout.
It's a little bit of rebellion,
malicious compliance.
You know,
Nana woke the fuck up from that.
You know what I mean?
At second of all,
she opens a door and he continues to
scream in her face.
So you know what I mean?
Like I wonder if it was a revenge cause
who this guy really seize the
opportunity.
You know,
I love that the crows are kind,
I don't think I've ever screamed.
It's like he took off
full breath.
Maybe this guy,
he was so passionate about pizza
understands.
He's like,
they might be in the backyard and I'd be
in the attic.
They might be four.
I need these people to know that I'm
here is so dedicated to it.
That's guy's a legend.
You're ready to,
exactly.
They've got some Mr Pib in the bag,
so that's,
these are people that respect pizza and
soda because you don't order Mr Pib
unless you're deep in it and what is
that?
It's an off brown.
Dr Pepper.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
She's laughing.
Oh,
I want more.
I want the,
I want to every Audi show that follows
this guy delivering pizzas.
Foppish message that the TLC.
Oh my God,
it feels good.
Pick that up.
One day the screaming pizza man.
Tonight I'll tlc.
TLC is on fire.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
TLC is on fire because we've been making
all these videos about Tlc and how
insane they are,
but I've never actually put on the
network and washed.
I'm like,
well,
this is all amazing stuff.
Why am I not watching Tlc?
We started recording the channel.
Yeah,
I started,
I started saving on Dvr.
All the programs.
I've been watching 90 day fiance,
Holy Shit.
This is the best show on TV.
I'm swear to God.
This is the most entertaining show on
television.
Um,
these guys will make a show about any
goddamn thing.
They have like five shows about little
people and giant people and giant people
and everyone in between.
I have this whole second,
but first I wanted to show this Tai
Lopez is using me in a fucking ad.
You believe this guy amber,
we made that video with Tai Lopez.
Yeah,
here.
H three here in my garage with ty Lopez.
It's an ad.
Okay,
the fuck tie.
This is all the Muma layers.
I know.
He was good.
I knew he had an echo from his ads and
now you're in his ass.
I don't think he's allowed to use our
footage.
Like is he?
I Dunno.
I saw this this morning and I tweeted,
I deemed him on twitter.
I was like,
ty,
what the deal with the crying?
Laughing Emoji.
Really?
Because soften the blow a little.
Yeah,
soften the blow,
but give me a fucking break.
Doug.
What is it?
Shit.
Did he reply?
I Dunno.
Shit.
Yeah.
And what the fuck tie.
Now you're using me to sell your shit.
I'm not.
I'm not even getting paid nine doors.
Singer message.
When we first saw his commercials on
youtube like two years ago,
if someone told you this did I would one
day they had one or two,
believe it.
Not for a second.
Ila,
I guess there is some kind of beautiful
poetry to to,
you know,
acknowledge in this that I'm sitting in
a Lamborghini and a Tai Lopez ad.
It's pretty amazing.
Yeah,
that is pretty amazing.
Jesus tie.
What do you think in doing this?
We've got to get him on the phone or
something.
So anyway,
I just wanted to point out that
beautiful little thing that happened,
but I've got clips from 90 day fiance.
Okay.
So this show,
first of all,
I've got to tell you guys this show,
every episode is two hours long.
We just found out yesterday like this
shit is so consumable.
We sat in bed,
the first episode we watched and we
didn't even notice.
We thought it was 30 minutes.
It was just all of a sudden it was like
1:30
AM and we're like,
whoa.
How did that happen?
By yesterday we were watching an
episode.
Yeah.
And it's been forever.
And then it sounds like,
how long is this?
It feels like we've been sitting here
for awhile and I was like,
I don't know,
40 minutes or something.
And we look and it's still all had been
already watching for an hour and a half.
And we thought we were watching a 30
minute show and didn't even notice our
episodes.
Hmm.
Your tlc is like Las Vegas.
Like they hold you there,
you know,
in Vegas they like don't have lights or
windows.
They like hold you hostage there and
kind of like hide the fact that you've
been hostage in their network for two
hours.
And even the commercials are interesting
because they show all the other weird
shows.
The Dev on til five,
lots of novasure yeah.
Oh yeah.
Self promote little people with giant
people.
And you were just laughing and all of
this.
So you were doing it.
We didn't even skip the commercials.
We really watched the whole two hours.
Right.
But um,
so 90 day fiance,
this show,
the whole premise is so insane and I,
and I,
and I stressed that.
I didn't even know how it's illegal
because first it's usually starts with
them overseas.
Well they have attorneys so it is legal,
whatever it is.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
they probably have some slick attorneys
making sure that they're not getting
deported.
But it starts overseas usually and then
they're bringing over on some kind of
visa and they have 90 days to decide if
they want to get married because they
have to decide the visa expires in 90
days.
Right.
So they have to decide,
am I going to marry you and immigrate or
do I not like you and I'm leaving.
And the people,
well,
first of all,
the people that would subject themselves
to this already fucked in the head.
Right.
It's really weird.
I Dunno.
They're apparently somehow in love.
They met somehow.
That's how it usually is.
I mean like who?
No,
I mean,
first of all,
who would invite Tlc cameos and to their
relationship during this difficult time?
It's insane.
Okay.
First of all,
second of all,
the way they select couples is like
incredible because they'll only,
they will specifically fine the people
that,
and you look at them and you say there
is no way that person cares about the
other person.
Yeah.
Cause like my favorite couple is this
Guy David and Annie.
This Guy David is a 45 year old,
he's overweight,
he's broke,
he has no prospect,
no prospects in life.
And the girl was like 24 24 sometime we
met and like,
and this is the reoccurring message.
There's no way to this other person
cares.
So it's like,
it's so,
hmm.
It's so scan.
It's like so juicy.
I'm only now realizing that I love
reality television because at first you
were reacting.
You're like,
oh this is garbage.
Who watches a shit?
But when you put on Tlc all the sudden,
you know,
like this,
I cannot turn off.
Yes.
I don't know.
Last night,
yeah,
last night,
the episode that we watched,
which we're going to show some clips of
it.
You got really depressing.
I don't know that I can keep watching
it.
It's amazing.
I wasn't depressed.
I loved every second of it.
I was getting and like actually nervous
for them and
you guys got to see this wall for me.
I was like,
Shit,
you thought you got marriage problems?
Tried dating David Thai massage.
This blew me out of my chair.
I said,
when I saw this,
I turned to gail and I says,
every moment of my life,
however difficult has been,
has it been worth it to watch this one
moment on Tlc?
I've lived a full life.
I said after I saw this one clip and I
was watching this live in the middle of
a two hour episode,
I was blown away.
So this Guy David,
and this is ty fiance there move,
he's so broke,
he can't even afford to get his own
place.
So there mooching off his best friend
and staying in their house.
So in this clip,
his best friend,
it's like,
well what are you going to do for me
that you guys are staying at our house?
And I'm telling you guys,
wow,
I love this.
I have to leave my country.
I have to leave my family for I go to
Walmart,
then starting line with nothing,
no money,
no job.
But I believe in David.
I believe in him.
It's still beautiful.
I love this.
Tonight we're having drinks with Chris
and Nikki before they hit back to
America.
Amy,
when any and I get to America,
we will be living with Chris and Nikki.
It makes sense to the,
I don't have a car.
I don't have an apartment.
I don't have a house.
I don't even have a US bank account.
Why did he specify us?
Big cause he lives in Thailand.
At least he is a charming,
young and handsome.
Do you still have our house ready for
you?
Are you excited about it
and exciting and scary?
Yeah,
we call it this very far from some of my
country and the very different
everything.
So live lands Differenci Paul,
Chris invited David and Annie to come
live with us.
Let's be clear.
This was not my idea at all.
And I tend to
to get excited and do things without,
um,
uh,
10 salting consulting.
So,
uh,
did you have some real estate you wanted
to talk about it?
Only being that I don't care.
I don't care.
Like our house is your house downstairs.
We'll share the kitchen.
Yeah.
Going bathroom,
you get your own little space,
you're welcome.
Um,
you know,
back on your feet,
you know.
Yeah.
Till we get situated there.
And obviously,
I mean even as we've talked about,
I mean it's a short term thing.
We have 90 days near your family to us,
my mind the whole time this guy is so
he's the most pathetic person I've ever
seen and I'm not,
I don't show the clip where,
but he's so broke and he's begging and
mooching from everyone and everyone's
like,
dude,
just get a job,
do anything.
And he's like,
it's just not that easy.
Ah,
crazy.
By days we can get through 90 days cause
we got just a little bit,
you know,
when you're on your 90 day visa,
you're not allowed to work.
But we would like you to,
you know,
maybe volunteer to do some things like,
volunteer to,
I know I like Thai food.
I would love you.
You love to cook.
Okay.
It's a little tight as we'd like it to
volunteer to cook for us.
He,
but he's asking her to be a maid,
which is fine.
It's not,
I mean it's a little strange the way he
puts it,
but guys,
buckle up.
I like to get massages.
I like Thai massage.
So is that something that you'd be cool
to,
you know,
volunteered at,
give me a massage or something about the
pool or
I massaged by the holy fuck.
This thing is the one I just,
I'm still,
I was hooked.
This was when I was up my legs and when
I gave up,
I can't,
well God,
I'm so worried for her.
This guy's such a creep,
but he says it in front of his wife,
who by the way has like a trillion miles
stare right now.
Like look her dead in the face.
You look in front of his best friend and
his wife.
Can I get a time massage by the
volunteer for a massage I love.
He was like,
what is this charity?
Can you volunteer?
Just,
how do you wrap your head around that?
The guy's a creep.
I love how he's like your tie.
So Thai food and Thai massage and a
happy ending.
Happy ending by the pool out this how
you do it in Thailand,
right?
Yeah.
Look at his wife.
She is so checked out,
man.
Ah,
so here it goes on the board.
He doesn't say anything.
He's like,
yeah baby.
Come on.
Everyone's just looking at it as well.
Yeah.
I was like,
I said,
I'm not making you do anything.
I'm just saying it would be nice.
Oh,
it goes on because they cut it short and
I saw the whole episode.
He goes,
uh,
she actually said no thank God.
Yeah.
She said no,
but she,
uh,
but I would be worried.
His friend was like,
oh,
well he told me that you give good
massages.
That's why I ask like,
he,
uh,
his,
what's his fucking name of David?
Put her,
put his friend up to asking her.
That's crazy.
[inaudible] is that good shit or what?
Two hours,
two hour,
two hours.
Holy Shit,
man.
Do you,
do you have any skepticism that it's
real?
Because like,
okay,
Dan Hour,
I ask myself all the time.
Yeah,
let me tell you this here,
right now.
I just don't accept that these people
are good enough actors.
The pull it off.
Have you worked like just doing sketchy
doing sketches for Rv?
It's very even a normal person that's
an,
that's been around performance in front
of the camera.
It's very easy to tell when someone's
acting.
Yeah.
I don't think that these are not even
like also the action.
They followed them for a month.
Like,
yeah,
like a on faith.
How does that couple do?
We made a video about,
you can still see youtube,
a youtube channels.
I think if anything,
the producers probably,
you know,
instigate the manipulate and manipulate
situations.
But um,
this is real as a heart attack,
dude,
this is real as a bowl of spicy my dog
and it gave me a heart attack.
This is real.
As a happy ending.
Can you imagine when he started saying
we would like you to volunteer?
I thought maybe they have a charity that
he wants her to come vulnerable.
You're at job.
He could just say maybe it'd be nice if
you could just help around the house.
That's reasonable.
That would have been pretty normal.
He's like listen,
uh,
but he had to make it like all about
like so your Thai Cook Thai food and uh,
I get me a fucking hand job every once
in a while.
So amazing.
You guys.
Um,
here's another one.
So this is like af months later,
I guess his friend is kicking him out of
the house.
Okay.
Cause he's been freeloading there for so
fucking long.
Actually,
let me show the wedding dress one first
told this guy is such a catch.
So here they are shopping for a wedding
dress.
Okay.
They,
they moved to the u s or they're living
with his friend.
Please.
For love.
I've,
I've picked out of 20 hours is a two
hour episode.
These wonderful moments for us all to
share together.
Okay.
Hmm.
Hello?
Yes.
Speakerphone.
Yeah,
I'm good.
I find the dress.
I literally lie it really.
Let me ask you,
I've,
I can't wait to see it,
but let me ask you one of the most
important question,
how much,
how much
this is a,
so you expect going to say like two
thousand three thousand right?
Like,
and I obviously,
you know,
things are tight.
You can afford that,
right?
So
routine with everything,
300 for a wedding and dealt with our
budget.
What do you expect her to where it's so
cheap for a wedding dress?
Dollars.
Of course it says chipping.
You can find deals.
Like I loved that I was on commenting
cheaper.
I love that.
She's like,
okay,
how much?
300 you cannot dress yourself for less
money for a wedding.
And that pause baby,
you know our budgets,
$20 it's amazing baby.
I told you,
go to the thrift store,
did a dollar.
She calls him from the thrift store.
I found when I like,
it's 50 bucks,
baby,
come on,
you're killing me.
Amazing.
But it gets better.
It gets better.
I really want to just think about how
many,
I want to say as much as I want you to
say yes.
300 solar.
I can looking good audio won't just make
it work.
So now,
so anyway,
let me fast forward.
Okay.
When they're buying it.
So I don't know where to run it as the
shit.
So they go to buy this $300 dress fay.
That's way out of their budget.
Yup.
It's a foreign car and we can't
yeah.
That the brand has to pay for it.
What do you do?
She's probably so sick of paying for
their ship,
but what does it,
yeah,
thank you.
Yeah,
I just show,
gives me,
cause that's so David,
I mean this is,
you cannot have a more awkward earning
our money back out with David will not
get a penny back again.
Yeah,
there we go.
Thank you so much.
Um,
so I'm burst and we cannot have what to
dress man.
Oh yeah.
How was that?
That's feel you feel that up there?
It's pretty yikes.
It's pretty x guys,
by the way.
Give us a ring anytime.
Oh,
we have calls.
Anything interesting here?
Uh,
pizza guy.
Well,
these are,
I guess is old news stuff.
Eight oh eight hot meme.
Give us a ring.
Um,
what else?
Okay,
so finally guys,
and I don't want to stay on this for too
long because we have many of them leave
to talk about,
but he later on visits with his sister
after being on the verge of being kicked
out.
Thank you so much.
And He,
oh,
it's so amazing you guys.
I'm doing this.
I really appreciate it and hope you like
it.
I haven't been here in 13 years.
I actually spent a long time does.
She was like,
hey away to come to their leg.
Identical.
I want her to be there.
I really did see kids couldn't miss
school.
I understood that.
So you've been here for a few months
now.
Yeah.
How do you like being cured?
So stuff's hard.
The complaint on top of that,
now I have to pay rent for the
firehouse,
which I was not expecting thousand
dollars a month.
How are you paying all this off?
I am Nance.
I asked myself this every day.
Um,
tremendously worried for both of you.
What's the solution?
Dude?
There's nothing saved.
He's got an idea.
What are you going to do?
Well,
so that's maybe where I can ask you.
Oh Jesus,
Jesus,
I came all the way down here for you to
ask me for money.
Ah,
this is painful.
Wherever you are in life,
whatever's going on,
man,
feel good.
You are whatever is going on.
You've got to be in a better position
than this guy.
That's true.
Fuck.
Love Him.
So there you go.
90.
So tlc is end summary.
The greatest place for entertainment on
television today.
They have the most
creative and adventure.
I like to know,
I'd like to be a fly on the wall during
the TLC executive like office who?
Green lights and red lights shows.
You know what I mean?
Cause they have the weirdest shit.
All their shows are about dwarfs or
giants or know what could be too weird
for them.
Nothing's too weird.
But like,
I wonder what it is.
He's red lighting.
You know what I mean?
That's a good question.
I really acted reality.
I want to know.
I want a reality show about the TLC
executive who green lights shows.
Yeah.
Um,
got it.
Cause the TLC executive today starring
the TLC executive
women who are attracted to horses.
I married a mayor tonight on Tlc little
people,
grave diggers.
It's about people that make little
people coffins,
not about when they got to be in love
with the car.
I don't know how to pitch something to
wear and love with the coffin people,
little people that like having sex and
little people,
coffins,
big wife,
little man.
It's about women that are over seven
feet tall with men under five feet tall,
pretty close.
And they use their head as a builder.
They got a show called my giant white,
my giant wife,
dude.
TLC is,
you need to be watching Tlc all day of
the week.
By the way,
this is just for my,
I love Washington.
This picture of Shaq and his girlfriend.
Okay.
They could make it,
they could be in a tlc show together.
It looks photoshop.
I sweat real.
I mean,
I think it's real dude.
Look up for,
I was,
I mean,
I've seen Shaq in prison.
He's enormous,
so like it makes sense,
but that's so absurd.
It looks fun.
I know,
I know.
I looked at so many,
I don't think it's photoshop.
I really didn't want to get gotten this.
But if I was at TLC executive about
greenlight,
this show,
I mean,
I,
you know what I'm thinking.
Right.
Okay.
How was she alive?
I mean,
his dick is probably the size of her
whole fucking leg.
Yeah.
How does,
how do they have sex?
I mean,
just,
frankly speaking,
his foot is the size of whole body.
Look at it.
Look at the size of his,
I think it is real.
It's real.
I,
that's what I'm thinking.
I did my due diligence.
His foot is the size of her whole body.
Yeah.
She gives birth every time they have
sex.
His Dick is like that big compared to
her body.
Right.
I mean,
she's the size of his pants.
No given birth.
Joe,
look at the size of his pants.
She's the size of his pants,
of his shorts.
I can't get enough of this photo,
man.
Okay.
You,
um,
show underneath and there is another
window.
Oh,
you should got another,
a vantage point of it.
Yeah.
Look at these guys.
I mean that looks real.
I'm townie scales about the same.
Yeah.
She doesn't even have to like,
all right,
am I getting too graphic?
Maybe.
Here's a good,
this one's photoshop.
They think this is so confusing cause
my,
Oh,
I can't turn your screen off.
All right.
Well when we come back,
um,
we got a lot to talk about.
We've got Kanye West is in Uganda.
We've got,
uh,
the shane finale to talk about.
We've got questions from our fans who we
love and so much more here and the
Gazebo zone.
Do not go away.
Listen,
what's left to say about this vibrating
tube.
Okay.
Now when I say vibrating Tube,
obviously I'm downplaying the
significance that this is one of the
greatest human advancements in the last
two to 3000 years.
Yes.
More advanced than fire or anything NASA
has ever achieved.
This is the quip electric toothbrush.
This toothbrush is everything I've ever
wanted in toothbrush.
First of all,
it vibrates superior brush.
Second of all,
it tells you when to switch quadrant.
So what you know how to get that perfect
two minute brush that dentists
recommend.
Third,
the bristles are soft and heavenly.
You don't have to be paranoid.
These are going to damage your gums or
teeth.
It's strong,
but soft and supple and best of all my
dudes,
quip electric toothbrush starts at 25
fricking dollars.
A couple of old toothbrush electric
versus how much is it going to run?
You have two,
300 bucks and it's like a huge brick.
It's like a whole,
it's like a car battery.
Give me a break.
Throw that shit out.
It's time to get quip electric
toothbrush and improve your game.
Guys,
that's what's up.
Also,
they send you refilled packs.
This thing pops off the top.
You put that on.
You're good to go.
It's quip electric toothbrush.
Okay,
get your first refill pack for 20 quip
starts@twentyfivedollarsgotogetquip.com
slash h three right now.
You get your first refill pack free with
the quip electric toothbrush.
Guys,
your first refill pack is free.
Go to g e t q u I p.com/h
three my doggies,
God bless.
Stitch fix is an online personal styling
service that finds and clothes,
shoes,
accessories that fit your body,
budget and lifestyle.
Just go to stitch fix.com/h
three tell them your size,
what styles you like,
and how much you want to spend on each
item.
You'll be paired with their very own
personal stylist.
You will hand pick items to send right
to your door.
Then you try them on pay only for what
you love and return the rest for pizza
sake,
shipping exchanges and returns are
always free.
There's no subscription required.
You can sign up to receive schedule
shipments or get your fixed whenever you
want.
The styling fee is only 20 bucks,
which is applied towards anything you
keep from your shipment.
So basically it's free.
If you keep something guys,
get started now@stitchfix.com
slash h three and you'll get an extra
25% off when you keep all the items in
your box.
That stitch fix dotcom slash h three to
get started today.
Stitch fix that guy.
Um,
[inaudible] dollar shave club's got it
all to look and feel and smell your very
gosh darn best.
In fact,
I love and you're going to love.
You don't have to go to the Dang store
and shop for Ray.
Races are so expensive at the store.
You and you have to go to the store and
talk to some 12 year old about what rate
you have to have a 12 year old come
unlock a case.
They keep rages behind cases.
No more dollar shave club's has no more.
Okay.
They deliver everything you need right
to your door.
They keep me fully stocked on what I
want and you don't run out.
That's the beauty of it.
They got everything okay for your hair,
your skin,
your face,
you name it,
they've got it.
And they've got a new program where they
automatically keep you stocked up on the
products that you use.
Do you determine what you want and when
you want it.
And it shows up right at your door for
once a month to every six months,
baby.
They got you covered.
And you never have to have another 12
year old unlock a glass case against so
you can get razors also.
They've got shampoo.
Ooh,
you can have them automatically sent
shampoo guys that got the whole frigging
packaged covered.
Do you shampoo your pubes guys?
I do.
Cause you want to keep a luxurious and
nice.
Um,
so then pube shampoo,
I believe they're marketing it as Bueb
and hair shampoo guys.
It's perfectly balanced,
not dry,
not greasy.
You pube your shampoos and you're
fucking good to go.
My dudes,
it's a plus.
You get they're handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
So guys,
right now you can shampoo your pubes.
Today they've got a bunch of starter
sets you can try for just five bucks
like this shower started set,
which includes the shampoo after that,
the restock box ships regular sized
products at a regular price.
So what are you waiting for?
Get your starter set for just $5
today@dollarshaveclub.com
slash eight three.
That's dollar shave club.com/h
three get shampooing your pubes today.
My Dude's welcome back to the Gazebo
zone and my good friends,
thanks for coming.
Um,
you know I talked about Lacroix previous
a previous episode and uh,
how the chemicals in it were safe for
consumption.
But um,
the truth is that uh,
I don't know how to set this up.
I got this bit plant cause I've been
working on my Alex Jones aggression,
but it felt really corny.
The weather.
Let me just do this.
Okay,
I got to Alex Jones.
Bet.
I've been working on your impression and
we've got this funny little thing,
so I'm just going to do it.
Okay,
so here's Ethan Jones.
Go ahead.
And so here we've got this green screen
and Ian is going to hold that right up
there.
Now last week,
Ethan Klein a liberal Jew out and spent
too much time in Los Angeles talking
about look,
Croix Beverages.
Now there is a chemical in lacroix.
Okay,
now bear with me here that when you
drink turns the fricking frogs gay.
Okay?
Now you could believe he declined to
liberal.
Who Says Lacroix?
Why is it some like funnel famous music?
Is this really the song we pick?
That's the one funnel.
Fancy bossfyte shit.
Now,
now,
now there's a chemical and lacroix,
okay.
That when you drink it,
And these liberals out here in
California,
there David sipping the,
the blood of babies for too long,
okay?
And you've got these inner dimensional
kind of feeds and they're zapping their
brains and tell him that La Croix is
okay.
But let me tell you the truth that bear
with me here,
okay?
There is a chemical in lacroix that when
you drink your testosterone levels get
so low,
think your penis actually gets sucked up
and pokes out of your butt hole,
okay?
Now the liberals want to take away your
masculinity.
They want your debt poking backward at
your butthole because they're cops,
they're liberals,
okay?
They're trying to demasculate you,
but you're a man.
That's why you take and for supplement,
okay?
And it may make you believe from your
eyes,
but at least it gives you a rock hard
cock,
okay?
So if you ask me,
if you ask me and I'll have my pressure
is falling apart,
it's pretty good.
Now if you ask me Alex Jones,
it changes.
I don't know why I had it so down.
If you ask me Ethan Jones,
there's a chemical in this beverage that
will take,
make your Dick poke right out of your
asshole.
Okay?
And so if you want to know how to get a
rock hard erection,
how you doing back there?
Hold it.
You doing good in funny.
Poke your head out and say that it was
going okay.
Thank you.
Hey,
I busted up now if you want a rock hard
cock,
put the lacroix down.
Okay,
you're a little soy boy.
Put down the soil substitute and take
info wars.
Black Rhino.
It's a supplement.
We got it from China.
We have ground up black rhino husks.
You take,
you shoot that in your veins.
It is freebased via an injection.
And let me tell you the last time I
injected this,
I had to go to the hospital.
They had to deflate the blood red or my
Dick.
I fucked for 20 hours.
It's fucking off.
I did believe from my eyes.
That is a minor side effect.
So that's about it.
I mean,
you guys were flying by the thank you
and we're done.
We're finished.
We're flying by the,
the the,
what's the phrase?
Pants seat on our pants seat of your
pants.
When does that mean?
I Dunno,
what do you think about Ethan Jones?
I like the special effects.
Yeah,
we're very,
the real life effect reminiscent of the
original star wars.
Very practical,
practical,
very practical.
Um,
I hope everyone had,
had really enjoyed that.
And now let me tell you about Ethan
client.
Okay.
This liberal Jew has openly admitted to
v I don't really like that this way.
I think this liberal Jew has openly
admitted to voting for Hillary Clinton,
who by the way has eaten at least 10
babies in the basement of a pizza joint.
Okay,
that's true.
Now if you are going to pick up a
lacroix,
you might as well eat a baby because
that's what the liberals in Hollywood
are doing.
Have you seen George Clooney?
He's 60 years old and he looks like he's
30 years old.
How does he achieve that?
Not by Jacob McCoy eating babies.
That's right.
Ila
[inaudible]
have you,
have you ever tried baby for skinny
yellow?
No.
Well that's your problem right there.
Okay.
Because if you want to look like George
Clooney at the age of 60,
you're going to need to inject baby for
skin and Tier Gooch test the area
between your asshole and vagina.
Very specific.
Okay.
Put down the Lacroix.
Let's turn to the fricking for obs gay.
All right,
I'm done.
Does anyone watch him?
Oh God,
we're trying stuff.
You know,
you might not think it's funny,
but it's under the Gazebos,
so we're free of cases.
I'm here today.
Okay.
Habif Kanye.
Now we talk about Kanye a lot on the
show because even specifically as a
super fan,
he's obsessed with Kanye and Kanye has
been just been all over the news.
Yeah.
He's been all over the place,
so it's hard to pass up the opportunity.
Now,
Ian pointed all these things out to me
and uh,
in,
you're going to have to help me
supplement the information that we have
here.
Uh,
now what's the background on this
journal entry in a,
he showed this to the president of
Uganda,
uh,
last week.
This is his to do list.
So he's in Uganda recording an album.
Right.
That's the best,
right?
That is correct.
Um,
so on his to,
this is just his to do list for the 15
now on this is included,
um,
transformed zoos.
That's something you'd like to
accomplish that out between three and
four o'clock,
we'd then we knocked out transforms.
It was real quick.
Start wave runner sport.
Okay.
Make Electric drone at least for that
week.
I love transformed zoos.
It's just like,
that was so 15th.
I'm on the 16th.
Babies' lives are different now.
Um,
what do you think about this list and do
you think this is an accomplishable list
or has he bitten off more than he can
chew?
Oh,
actually it says day 15,102,
I think.
Oh,
she's,
the amount of daisy's been alive,
I think.
Yeah.
What this guy on?
No,
that's not divided.
Well let's divide that.
It doesn't sound like enough date.
I don't think you crunched the numbers
on this end.
15,000
divided by three 65 you're looking at,
no,
he's right.
He's 41 years old.
Hey Dan,
you put,
you sowed doubt in my mind about Ian's.
Never doubt when it comes to Konya.
I never,
never questioned.
So do you think he's bitten off more
than he can chew him?
What his column there it looks like.
Yeah.
And I mean I think the fourth one down,
speak to George LucasLucas' wife.
I think very doable.
Accomplish accomplishment for him.
He'll definitely smart.
That one.
Also invite Wellsmith to record.
That's very doable.
I mean he just invites him transform.
Zoos seems a little more complex than
those,
but what do I know?
I'm not calling you with,
um,
we've got other things.
He,
he's in Uganda,
uh,
working on music and here he is passing
out yeezys to poverty stricken Uganda.
Ugandans.
Now the funny thing,
I had a couple of thoughts about this.
First of all,
these kids don't know what do they feed
their family with the,
you know what I mean?
And the second thought,
I had one pair though,
probably like a year salary.
I wonder if some guy,
some dudes with machetes are going to
come club them over the head and still
there easily.
So
it's like just his outfit.
It's so fun and like it's all Balenciaga
and all this like high design or
expensive designer clothes.
I don't know.
The whole thing is too funny.
I just,
that Kanye is response to like any
situation pass out easys like on talk
shows.
Jimmy Kimmel came out and easy trump,
he gave a pair of yeezys Uganda yeezys
for everybody.
And do you think this is a fair piece
offering or was easy as not
inappropriate gift?
He gave some to the president of Uganda
to and he was like thanks for the
sneakers.
So they don't,
they definitely don't know it.
Yeezys are,
I don't pay enough for the kids know the
president promised thanks for the
sneakers.
He's like,
why are you giving me shoes?
thanks for the sneakers.
You dip also those as are so white
that's not going to stay wide.
Not in Uganda.
I Dunno if that means,
I dunno.
They're just outside.
They're always starting.
Shit,
I don't leave the house.
I think in Uganda they're outside war
it.
Do I need to apologize for that because
that a racist a yes.
You know,
is it racist of me to assume that people
in Uganda are outside more?
It's grassy,
you know,
there's dirt dirty,
it's dirty.
It's dirty air and Uganda,
there's more dark there.
Is that racist?
Forgive me.
Do I need to apologize?
I apologize to all Ugandans.
It stared there.
It's dirty there,
right?
Yeah,
no comment.
Um,
so that was a joy to behold all these
kids.
No,
but seriously,
if there's someone in Uganda that knows
the true value of those that you can
resell it on Ebay for like 500 bucks.
Okay.
Aren't those kids are in danger,
right?
I mean,
am I wrong in back me up here?
Shaking his head?
No,
he doesn't think they're,
they have your back.
He doesn't.
Okay.
Ian Does.
Is Uganda Dirtier in general?
Back me up.
Yeah.
I've never been.
I Dunno.
All right.
All the pictures I've seen,
it looks quite beautiful.
I'm just saying there is campaigning and
I apologize to all the Ugandans.
I apologize for my ignorance statements.
It was actually my statement,
but you're kind of always handmade.
Fuck's wrong.
So backwards.
Um,
okay.
This one's wild.
He built like a whole dome city out in
the middle of like a,
well,
why don't you tell me and you know,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
Uh,
some national park
and he rented out.
Yeah.
Get some audio going with that.
He's having too much money.
Is there any other background you'd want
to share?
You in?
You just kind of trailed off on,
he rented out a,
he rented out this entire lodge just for
him and his people and then he built
these like these dome things in,
uh,
in the middle of the wilderness.
Okay.
Very nice.
I feel like that's a really fun way to
workshop your music.
You shouldn't record it cause it sounds
really stupid.
But he's workshop again.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
It's just like some guy in the car.
He,
okay.
Yeah.
Carry on
the gas on a head on with banana.
Ah,
what the hatchet gave the kids some
yeezys and they say it's easy common
with Michelle and you get there.
Is that,
is that what you heard in or do you hear
genius?
Right.
It's a process.
It's a process that everyone on the
Kanye forums listening closely,
like I dare you to say shit.
We know who you are now,
motherfucker.
Huh?
Some say yeezy,
yeezy,
blueberry.
Others say scoping it.
Goopy berry.
All right,
stop Ethan.
That was pretty good.
I think you should go to Uganda.
Dude.
I don't have enough.
Easiest fast out,
uh,
teddy fresh.
They'll take any fresh.
Here's some new sandals.
They're all dancing and she had the same
way.
It's Uganda.
I apologize.
It's a smaller buckets.
You've gone though.
I'm just saying I'm not insulting the
country of the people.
Those fuckers probably slip on like 10
cents a day.
Is that in salt?
Is that,
is that wrong?
What's the daily salary of a Ugandan
daily income of a gun?
Ugandan.
I don't think we really need to.
Um,
here,
let's find out.
Annual income is,
oh my God,
dude.
What'd you got?
Monthly income for a household.
A household that's a whole family is 280
bucks monthly.
Yeah,
for a household.
Yikes.
So what I'm saying,
it's very poor country.
My sandals,
my use sandals costs like 30 bucks.
Okay.
Just say played a poopy Doo.
He was like,
move on.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
It is asking for the puppet.
He's scoop Kanye out in Uganda,
which I will deliver to you now.
This is the farm team.
Kanye daily.
Ian,
are you following team Kanya daily on
twitter.
I've got him.
Yeah,
you're got them covered.
Okay,
good.
Runs that account.
This is fire,
right?
All the animals in the jungle.
He doesn't seem like he's good.
He's very serious about the scoop and
the whoop titties.
You know all the junk.
This is like all the animals in the
surrounding area because he's in the
middle of the wilderness are like
fleeing.
They're gonna fucking,
it's like the elephants that looks
stampede.
A village cause stuff.
Yeah,
they're just,
they're heading for a highlander.
You get chills when you hear this again.
As a fan,
you have Chelsea in.
Do you want to break?
Do you want to deconstruct the lyrics?
I've got goosebumps.
Do you think he's just having fun or is
he really trying to workshop something?
I think he eats a bit about,
yeah,
he's having a blast.
He's been on the,
the scoop,
the poop train for a while now.
I was just a recurring theme.
I'm a fan of the scoop.
Did he poop?
No question about it.
Um,
we've heard a lot about you're scooping
poop.
Yeah,
it's definitely,
you know,
Connie scopes the poop.
That was this incident.
Now he's a front wiper.
Now we know for sure.
Connie is a fan of this show because one
the purple hat and to his biggest hit of
the year poop scoop.
Scoop the poop.
Okay.
Um,
I've,
I'm a fan of these creepy ass robots and
there's a lot more that came out.
I want to show you guys,
um,
this is called the Mat Hos Robot,
Aka the park core robot.
Boldbock Boston dynamics of these
motherfuckers.
We're going to look back in 20 years.
We should have stopped them when we had
the chance.
You know,
like,
oh,
everyone's laughing and it's trending on
Youtube.
Boston dynamics.
We should have stopped them.
Look at this robot.
Not even Matt Hos cut out pork or this.
See Ya.
Hey,
looks like a,
it looks like it's,
uh,
a computer rendering.
Yeah,
because he leaps so effortlessly.
This robot is jumping up blocks.
I hate this robot is going to,
are you kidding me?
What chance do we
have against these parkouring robots?
Like,
are you fucking kidding me right now?
stop them now.
You know what I'm saying?
That can be used for good.
You know what good is a park Hong robot,
except they chase you down.
You know?
That's a good question.
Actually.
The next video we'll show you what?
Good.
Oh,
this is the good.
Okay.
Elo Elo's correct of me.
This is the good more bus.
You know,
they're just trying to make it cute,
but this thing is fucking dead.
He's dancing.
Okay.
Is what it does over your corks.
Yeah,
right,
exactly.
He's dodging bullets right now.
Moonwalking I don't like it.
Lasers are sipping Mai.
I don't like it.
Yeah,
that's it.
We should have stopped them.
And we had the chance.
4 million views.
Everybody loves.
Everyone's having a good time.
We should have intervene now.
Little 12,
the robot dance.
It's so funny.
No,
this was our chance.
You know,
terminator,
they sent Terminator and back in time
to stop the inevitable before it
happened.
That's us now.
Okay.
Don't,
I'm afraid someone's actually going to
go do something to buff,
man.
I'm joking.
For Christ's sake.
I'm scared though.
And we must intervene.
Give him easy's.
That'll chill them out.
Um,
what else now,
speaking of Gazebos,
these guys.
Okay,
so a lot of comments.
Let's,
let's go back to our new video.
Okay.
Our new video was about the Tlc cat fish
and this whole thing about gazebos and
stuff.
And the host of that show was,
um,
God,
what's his full name?
I know his name,
Elliot,
but I don't remember if Morgan Elliot
Morgan.
Um,
I hadn't met him once on the set of
smarsh.
I did a game show with him on smash and
I realized only about halfway through
recording because he looks super
different.
Like now he's got a beard.
I was there,
him too,
but I didn't realize it was him.
But,
um,
at whatever you guys get it.
But he,
he,
uh,
it looked like him,
but I didn't believe it was the same
person.
And,
um,
but then you pointed it out,
I was like,
doesn't it all look like Elliot?
This is halfway through recording where
he started the video and she's like,
no way.
And I was like,
yeah,
you're right.
There's no way,
but it looks so much like him.
It's kind of uncanny.
And then I look up the credits of the
show and sure enough,
it's Elliot.
Now a lot of people are like,
why didn't you mention,
well,
I didn't want to,
I didn't,
I wasn't trying to personally attack the
guy.
Yeah.
I thought it was best to not mention him
by name or even to acknowledge it
because I didn't,
I didn't want to give the Guy Shit,
I don't want to fuck him up.
You know?
We just make it fun to show,
I'm kind of the persona he was playing.
Yeah.
You know,
it's probably not his show,
you know,
so it's not really like,
yeah,
he's project.
Yeah,
I hope none.
And I'm just,
I'm not leaving to go after people
personally.
I'm just,
yeah,
that's not,
I'm just not trying to do that.
And so we were trying to think like,
how do we,
uh,
how do we address it?
This,
that we've actually met this guy and I
thought,
you know what,
let's just not even mentioned this guy.
I don't,
I'm not trying to fuck this guy's life
up.
But,
um,
they fired back actually really funny
video and I appreciate them so much
because this is how you embrace it.
The meme,
super funny guy,
the valley folk is that gets a sketch
comedy troupe.
Could you say,
could you,
yeah.
Could you,
uh,
describe the former source fed people?
Oh,
it's all of source fed guys.
Okay.
So the valley,
the valley folks.
So they made a sketch and response to
that Ngozi Bros.
So I thought we could enjoy it here
today in honor of them embracing the
main shut up to Elliot Morgan.
God bless him.
Yeah.
Did you see the h three h d totally
roasted Elliot's Tlc show?
Let me turn it up.
So then again,
I haven't really ever hosted Elliot
Partial Shit.
Don't you start over again?
Because I talked over and I really watch
the youtube video in like 15 years.
That sounds pretty good.
Thank you.
Hello.
I am a 14 year old girl looking at
fraud.
Did you see you can make fun of Elliot
for doing that really bad fish show.
Yeah,
I did Joe.
That's why I'm in here.
I'm hiding from residual embarrassment.
Jokes aside,
dude.
What kind of moron goes on a cap?
This show.
It's good company.
I like Ariana Grande Day and coffee.
Dear Google,
do actions have consequences or can I
get away with Elliott Elliott?
What's up?
Did you see that Ethan from h three h
three roasted your ass on national
internet?
Well,
no,
I didn't go.
You haven't seen it?
I don't know if I want him.
Oh Man.
Okay.
Um,
get ready to,
I think he was probably,
when he saw that I made a video about
it,
he was probably like,
like,
oh fuck,
here we go.
But I didn't want him to watch it and
feel bad.
That was my,
so I hope he didn't based on the
response.
I mean they took it and uh,
and I think they definitely made the
best of it.
I mean the video did really good and
they made a really funny video response
to that.
Yeah.
So there you go.
And then also feel the cold tied to
professional shame wash over your body.
Okay,
Joe?
Well here's the thing.
I mean Internet comments are just
manifestations of truths.
I came buried deep within for fear of
confronting them head on.
You don't need to act like you're a
predator.
You have a zip thing.
He looks so much different.
Yeah.
He's all shave.
He looks like
so young,
like a suite.
They styled him to be like this sweet
young,
a Christian boy.
Yeah.
They tried to dress style him.
So they're like this guy could never be
considered to be a predator.
He's too sweet and good and too good of
a good Christian old boy,
you know?
Yeah.
Bearded Elliott on the other hand
definitely could never have hosted that
show.
I'm kidding.
Can I mention the most fucked up part of
this is it they're having her meet him
at a
good,
it's either this guy is fucking good.
It's pretty fun.
What is pretty,
pretty funny.
Yeah,
it was,
how are you going to respond?
A probably very stoically Joe and uh,
with a,
a dry sense of humor,
something that conveys authenticity but
it's also brand appropriate and most of
all,
most importantly tantamount.
I will not embarrass myself.
Very reminiscent of Gamer goals.
What's the best way to respond to
Internet ridicule?
And this is what I found.
Oh,
revenge.
Gay.
Yeah.
I mean I don't want to get political,
but it's an option,
so,
oh yeah.
Well guess what?
Sometimes it looks like you kind of have
a double chance and maybe work on that.
Got Him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Anyway.
Yay.
You get a gold watch.
They'll hold guys to go watch it and it
is really fun.
And Yeah,
these guys are great.
Very charming.
Very uh,
very,
very good.
Very nice.
The valley folk.
So shout out to these food per troopers
out there.
May I may they join us under the Gazebo
here today and all hold hands
delightfully under the Gazebo.
So shout out to all those guys.
Very,
very sweet.
Um,
no elliot's sweetheart.
I mean I only met him that one time.
Very sweet,
very nice guy.
Very happy to share the stage with the
guy.
Um,
and uh,
I wish him all the very,
very best.
And uh,
I do,
I have some questions for him.
I wouldn't,
maybe we should have a call cause one
I'm curious,
was that his clothes or did they make
him wear that shirt with a zipper on it
too?
I'm wondering how much was stage.
I'm afraid to ask though because I,
I don't,
I'm afraid to find out it was all fake.
I must don't want to know that.
I don't know if we can't even tell you.
That's curious and there's probably an
NDA.
TLC doesn't fuck around.
Um,
maybe,
but again,
this goes back to thing.
I don't think that that little girl in
those parents or can be that good of
actors to convincingly act that,
you know what I mean?
Well,
the parents were okay.
I think the girl would convince me that
it's real.
If she was acting,
she's got a bright future,
you know?
Yeah.
But then that's also what I wonder is
like if they're that good and they're
trying to be actors,
why don't we see these people in other
things you don't?
Yeah.
Conclusion.
TLC is real.
Shout out to the valley folk out there
and God bless.
Uh,
here's a great one.
How's everyone doing today?
Let me check the calls.
Anyone here?
Grandmother passed away.
Wanted to thank you.
Thank you.
I mean,
hey,
thanks.
That's the note.
Appreciate a pizza guy.
How does this,
just trying to figure out how to do
these calls.
He's an air force high ranking officer.
We've got a general on the line.
Wanted to ask about possible future
guests for the show.
Okay,
well thanks to everyone for holding.
I think that I will not take any calls.
Sorry.
Um,
should I take this pizza guy?
He says had a similar experience as the
pizza guy.
How interesting.
Can that be?
I'm not sure.
Move on that air and think we need to
give people instructions of what kind of
calls do you want.
Yeah.
I want them to be more topical.
You know,
like we were talking about the creepy
robot that has a park or robot ever
chased you down and murdered your
family.
Cause that happens every day.
Or someone who's got a question about
Kanye or something,
you know,
or some comment like that,
expand on the conversation where we're
having,
you know,
um,
yeah,
we're working on it now.
Do you guys want to watch this?
Watch this little twists here for you?
It was a great one.
Yeah.
I love this fucking guy.
Everyone clap.
Yep.
This dude just take a fucking nap.
MMM.
What?
It's not even a play.
Um,
I love that.
I love trump.
He's good.
He's really well read.
Anyway.
How Hitler?
Yup.
He says it's so fast.
They didn't process it.
He's like,
listen,
trump's great.
I've read his book.
He's super intelligent.
I love his politics.
I think he's great for the country.
Anyway,
Heil Hitler,
I love you.
Got To end.
Any point you make with that from now on
anyway,
how Hitler but the audience,
everyone in the audience is rocking.
This guy in the red takes a bite of it.
Takes a bite of a sandwich on the Heil
Hitler.
Well,
actually this shit,
damn,
that's a weird one.
I,
uh,
I'm a huge fan of,
of trump's platform.
He's got a lot of smart things about
immigration.
He's bringing jobs back.
You know,
his tariffs I think are good for
America.
Big Fan love America.
God bless everyone.
And a High Hitler.
Love your passion.
Love your enthusiasm.
It's so anti.
It's so,
you cannot be an American and a Nazi.
They are water in oil.
Okay?
You cannot throw a Heil Hitler in
America.
You just can't do it.
I don't know your works in any country.
It works in some countries than Ohio.
I've just saying America out in the
public like that.
That's a fair,
that's a fair point.
You make a fair point.
Heil Hitler.
You forgot the Heil Hitler at the end.
Um,
read his book.
Huge Fan.
He's a real intellectual.
How Hitler,
he's a d.
You're endorsing trump,
not Hitler.
What does hillary could all this praise.
He's fucking gone.
You know you're talking about trump.
Hmm.
He likes it.
He likes Hitler as well as trump.
Hmm.
Fascinating stuff.
Um,
fat.
Oh this one is was really bad for me.
Fat.
You guys know what a fat burger is
either on my whole,
unfortunately I do.
So we've had an ongoing debate about
baby wipes here on the show and I love
baby wipes.
I'm a huge proponent of baby wipes one.
Unfortunately this kind of started
seeping into my reality that flushable
is misleading.
Yeah.
Extremely misleading.
This here on during the podcast,
it's been a hard truth to swallow.
Um,
a lot of people were like,
Hey Ethan,
I want you to know those are actually
flushable.
And I'm like,
yeah,
eat.
I was like suck my tiny Jewish dick and
I have stopped flashing them by.
You didn't,
well I think that,
okay,
let me give you an anecdote.
I mean this morning I went white.
What?
And there's a lot of shit on it cause I
got to do more dry them.
And then it seemed fine.
It seemed ready to go,
but it wasn't,
but it seems like when you go wet,
it is probably generally,
you know,
less what's going on with this mic.
God,
it's like all over the place.
Um,
Jesus,
when you wipe,
when you go wet,
I have a feeling that's nicer maybe,
but when I go wet,
it's fucking wild.
When you don't want that,
you know,
we're gonna see,
but you don't want a shit covered wet
wipe of mine and the Trashcan,
you have your own trashcan.
I'm telling you,
you'll smell it.
Think so.
We have separate bathrooms.
Um,
but uh,
so apparently there's a phenomenon of
people flushing what wet wipes of raw
sewage flushable quote unquote flushable
wipes and hair turning into such a huge
cluster of,
of shit that it's actually clogging huge
city main pipelines.
So the danger is actually not to your
home pipes,
but the danger is to the city pipes.
Everyone.
Yes.
And the city is spending millions of
dollars to take out these proverbial fat
burns.
They're called that I'll share with you
here today,
but I don't know.
I mean,
um,
mmm.
Chris,
Chris had the perfect rebuttal to when I
was like,
you know,
some people flush the baby wipes.
And he said,
uh,
their shit on them.
And I was like,
yeah,
there's shit on them.
Why don't you just take a shit in the
trashcan?
Well,
why didn't you open it up and show feels
law savoring the moment here developing
on developing here.
So the Charleston water,
these guys have been on a tear lately.
This is the Charleston water system.
These guys are killing it on twitter
verified and everything.
Um,
they've been doing psa is about these
fucking Fatberg.
So here you go.
Diverse swim these.
Now that's a hero.
Forget about a mascot in a burrito
getting punched.
That's not courage.
That's not a hero.
A hero is a die.
Well,
maybe it is,
but I'm not going quantify courage,
but diverse.
Swim through 90 feet of raw sewage to
unclog giant hairy Fatberg.
Can you fucking imagine you're diving
through raw sewage?
Damn,
I can't see this.
You see that?
Like,
that looks like something from a scary
movie.
Like an,
like a monster.
It kind of looks like my profile.
No,
no.
Ken Hair.
So this is just shit.
I find it intriguing that sewage turns
black cause shit is brown obviously,
as we all know.
What interesting.
So you want to take a bite of that?
What'd you take a bite of that?
How much should they go about it?
That I can barely look at it.
Just on the computer.
It's spaghetti to marinaded spaghetti
anyway.
Yeah,
it's awful.
It is awful.
So I stand corrected on the issue of
flushable baby wipes.
And by the way,
I find it pretty wack that they can
advertise it as flushable when it's
clearly a completely not flushable.
Yeah.
Like literally not flushable.
How is that legal?
I mean,
I find it to really be the fault of
these manufacturers that they're able to
get away with this deceptive marketing
because when I buy a flushed and we'll
away,
there's a whole market for flushable
wipes.
I'm assuming that this is somehow,
yeah,
a valid statement.
You know,
it's crazy.
I can't believe,
I dunno.
I find that to be some kind of false
advertising.
Um,
there's,
there's so much more Fatberg they're
called,
which is a great,
lovely name.
Um,
hope you guys are hungry.
Look at,
this is the brave fuck that goes in
dives and still raw sewage and wonder
what those guys get paid man.
Dot Picture.
Um,
move.
Right?
Like that's a whole,
it looks like this crazy fuck.
He's not even wearing protection.
His sleeves are out.
Okay.
He's proposing with the Fab Berg,
his arms are exposed,
his face is exposed.
That's courage.
It's pretty to that guy is.
So yeah,
this is like a crazy operation.
Then look good.
I look at all the work they do too.
They says,
do you use flushable wipes in your home?
Turns out they're not so flushable after
all,
in fact,
they just caused a major citywide,
a water pump clog and Charleston,
Charleston water says is becoming a huge
issue for them too.
We break it down tonight.
Oh Wow.
There's a whole investigation going on.
Okay,
so what are you going to do about it?
I think I'm going to get some bad days.
I think I'm going to get the days
installed.
I really liked these photos.
These are these crazy ones.
We tried it when we were in Montreal,
but I had diarrhea.
So my,
I don't know if I talked about this,
I have like really crazy diarrhea.
And so my asshole was super sore from
wiping so vigorously.
And so when I shot the water,
my asshole to her,
cause I'd look open wounds so I didn't
get to enjoy it that much.
And then when I,
cause it's like a communal toilet.
It has a fan setting.
So it's um,
oh,
it has a dryer.
First of all,
it has a fan.
So when you sit on it,
it's sucks in the air.
It's sucks the shit smell out of there.
I swear to,
I swear to you right now and then,
but the weird thing,
so it's sprays your asshole.
And then the problem that I had with it,
frankly speaking,
because everyone talks about these big
days,
like they're,
you know,
heaven sent and this is a,
this is what I fear what happened,
but water dripped down my balls.
Shitty water was dripping down my balls
for for fuck sake.
Hmm.
Torn.
Probably need to learn how to use it.
You know,
how do I avoid water shooting down my
ball and take some learning.
Okay.
I'm willing to learn.
But the weird one for me,
because this isn't a hotel so this has
had a lot of people shit.
Um,
the seat was warm.
Love that the seat comes up when you
approach it.
Love that.
But then they have a dryer setting cause
they know that your balls are all wet
and your asshole and everything's all
wet.
And then the dryer smelled like it was
blowing shitty.
Aaron,
my face.
That sounds gross and like not,
why did you have your face in the toilet
bowl?
I didn't damn it smelled like I needed
a,
I needed some fresh squirt water on my
face.
It's a little pick me up.
But though,
so it wasn't like my shit smell though.
It was like this shit smell of like
thousands before me.
Oh yeah.
In that hotel.
So it's billowing like shitty air.
Like Fatberg air goes.
Yeah.
So that I had a problem with but,
but I think I'm going to go the
[inaudible].
I feel like we are responsible probably
for telling a lot of people to use baby
wipes brought with the amount of baby
wipes.
I flush.
I'm personally responsible for
destroying the septic system ups of all
of Israel and Los Angeles and New York.
So I take it back and say that I do not
use them anymore.
We're moving the endorsement of
flushable so called flushable baby
wipes.
Yeah.
And um,
I'm going to,
I think I'm going to go the bid day rope
the toe toes to try it.
I mean,
even the thing that I always,
I love this thought,
the King of England.
How did he wipe his ass?
You know what I'm saying?
Like back in the day when the king was
like God and he's got like literally
gold woven dresses that he like lifts up
and shits,
does someone wipe his ass?
You know what I mean?
I don't think so.
You think that king gods gods,
what'd you mean?
The Queen does?
Oh,
of England.
There are more modern.
She's more modern.
She hasn't felt though.
No,
but I'm taught,
this is pre toto.
This is pre modernity.
This is God's spokesman.
This is the clue.
This has god basically the King of
England.
You think he wipes his own ass?
We're all human after all.
Not King George.
I bet you he had peasants like I bet you
he laid on his back and some servant
fucking cleaned his asshole.
I think so.
I bet you there's a history historian.
Who knows.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
I'm going to fucking google searches.
Did King George wipe his own?
Drop the link.
It's got a nice little illustration in
there too.
Although I'm not talking specifically
the King of England.
Why did medieval kings have servants to
wipe their butt for them?
Couldn't they just do it themselves?
Why is this guy act like he knows for
top answers?
What makes you think they'd dig?
Can you give me a source in this?
I've never heard of it.
Oh Man.
Okay.
This is the,
this is the kind of history that we need
to learn about.
Dan,
what did you drop me here and all times.
How did now see,
Oh God,
this illustration is ill.
It was mostly,
why is this safe to show since you're
writing?
Yeah,
I guess so.
Look at this shit,
but this is not the king of England.
Do you understand?
Look at her as a fine upper class woman
though.
Is She paying in a bowl?
I would think so.
Yeah.
So you did it.
God,
it's come a long way.
I love how on one hand they're like so
over the top with how they dress and
behave.
And then on the other hand she's paying
in a bolt.
You know what I mean?
Hmm.
I have a feeling that King George of,
of England at the height of his power
didn't wipe his own ass.
Sorry.
Medieval king.
Okay,
here you go.
There's actually a,
mmm.
Um,
I'm reading a,
this is important guys.
Bear with me.
All right,
I'm closing this.
I'm out.
Somebody back there,
see if you can find the answer to that
because this is important.
Shame.
The Shane Jake Paul series has come to a
finale that's finally over.
It's finally over.
The final episode was posted at almost
two hours long.
Oh my God.
It was two hours long.
There's two moments that really want to
share with you guys and they're short,
they're sweet.
I'm not going to get into the whole
thing,
but I guarantee you're going to love
this.
So,
um,
let's pull this clip up.
So this one,
Alyssa Violet,
who's Jake Paul's ex girlfriend,
and then she slept with Logan Paul.
Um,
and she begged him,
please,
we made a mistake.
Don't tell anybody that we slept
together.
Logan's response was the best.
Let's hear it.
We just go to a club like we normally
would do and just hung out and then
crank and it was just a bad decision and
we'll our parts,
we checked it after and you were like,
I was like,
ever like coaching.
You cannot rule on the skirt out.
Like it was so stupid.
And he was like,
listen,
like who savage,
how far?
That's all.
I love that.
She's like,
please don't tell anyone.
And he said,
listen,
I'm a savage,
I'm a maverick.
And then he made like a whole disc track
about it and stuff.
She was in it by the way.
So I don't know.
I really don't know what's what with
this shit.
I tell you what,
the new,
the new video has over 10 million views
and it's twoF and hours long.
Mike.
God,
somehow he tricked people in the Wa like
it used to be.
Everyone was like,
I'm so sick of Jake Paul,
right.
And Somehow Shane has found a way to
trick people and the watch in 150
million views in the Jake Paul.
It's brilliant.
Um,
so there you go.
I'm a maverick and then second of all,
this one of Greg Paul trying to crowd
surf great.
Paul is the biggest fucking Douche on
the planet.
That's what I've determined.
If anything from this.
Yeah,
just don't do it.
And these are kids
demand.
They can't bear the load.
Watson
slowly
12 year olds.
My Dude,
don't jump on kids the way.
Just a kid.
I got to watch that again.
It's like,
dude,
don't
just say,
you know what?
Not For me.
I'm 50 years old is so young in spirit.
Yeah,
he's got a tie.
Dye.
Age is nothing but a number comes from
Patrick.
Kelly said,
come on baby.
Ain't man doesn't want a number.
Did R Kelly right?
That for like his 15 year old
girlfriend.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's love man.
That's crazy.
Our a fuck.
Yup.
People used to get away with shit.
They don't get away with it now.
Like can you make a pile polo gang away?
Apparently having a coke.
So people do get away with stuff still.
But can you imagine a pop star being
like age ain't nothing but a number baby
cause 15 year old girlfriend.
Okay.
It's kind of what great Paul does.
Allegedly.
Okay.
I like it.
Let's hit,
let us listen.
Joy as he,
I'm going to hit you with the slow
motion because I want to see this play
by play.
I got to savor this moment where this is
the end of the documentary guys and this
is the best part.
Okay.
Ah,
the guy thinks he's like a rock star
man.
There's a bunch of 12 year olds trying
to pair your fat ass like a bag of dirt.
There's some poor kids.
I don't,
I'm getting squashed.
That is nightmarish by the way.
Turn down the music.
Yeah.
But anyway.
Um,
so out of the two hour documentary,
that is pretty much shit like eight
hours total,
something like that.
Seven hours.
Guys,
if you have questions,
comments,
suggestions,
videos,
something you want us to talk about or
watch,
email
us@podcastaththreehthreeproductions.com
today.
Our first question comes from Nada
either on a podcast,
not that long ago you mentioned one of
your old videos,
shake that Dick and quickly shoved the
topic away in embarrassment.
You've even removed the video from the
channel,
which further perpetuates the idea that
you are ashamed.
But I believe that it was one of the
funniest things you ever made.
So I think you should react to it and
tell us how you came about making it and
how you convinced eight people to cheer
you on as you shook your Dick for you
too.
Have a blessed day.
Thank you for that.
Yeah,
it's embarrassing.
I mean it's like my deck,
like you see my deck.
It's like the whole outline.
It's every,
it's very embarrassing.
I feel like maybe it's a good
suggestion.
Maybe we shouldn't make a video.
Yeah.
If an like an h three video because that
is the one video that my dad saw us.
The good story.
I got this,
I got this stone for that video.
That was the last video I shared on my
facebook page.
The lore behind that video,
that was pretty good.
I think if anything can make a good age
three video,
but like is it,
am I,
is it appropriate?
Can we show that footage?
Because it's like the outline of my Dick
Underpants.
Yeah.
You think that's fine?
I mean you don't actually see how you
don't see my deck,
if,
you know,
cause you can see like titties,
like you could see like a tit outline
under a shirt and that's fine.
That was the whole joke,
right?
Where's the Dick?
You get the teddies you get to ask,
where's the deck?
I'll think about it.
Not a,
but,
um,
how did we convince those people on the
street?
Those were real people sitting on the
street and we were just like,
Hey,
do you guys mind getting a little like
excited for us?
The video,
I think he's talking about the party at
the end.
Oh,
I thought of
the old dude actor ever.
We'll save it.
We'll talk about it.
I think there's enough floor behind that
to make an interesting,
this one comes from Marv.
Hey guys.
So those people were my friends.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Well those are my art.
Plus they were well aware with our
antics by then.
Marv.
Hey guys,
I'm ashamed to admit it,
but I'm one of those people that eat
buggers.
It's been a habit of mine for as long as
I can think.
I'll eat burgers probably once or twice
a day less if I'm a lot of people and
more if I'm alone and board.
I got good at hiding it from people.
He's like an alcoholic.
I hide my alcohol around the house.
I wonder if he at wonderful put a booger
under the table and then when people
leave he takes it off and eats just
dance.
While I'm trying to help the guy with
hobby,
I got good at hiding it from people.
Even for my girlfriend of five years,
she's as she never knew as far as I
know,
even though I know it is disgusting,
I don't feel disgusted.
It's weird and I'm more,
uh,
I'm more disgusted with myself that I
keep doing it.
It's an urge that is hard to suppress,
but I feel like at least I do it less
than I used to.
I tried to use other methods of
disposing of boogers if they're
available and convenient,
but I'm a bit more,
it sounds like too,
this is intense.
Um,
I'm a bit more hesitant to do it if I
know I breathed through some weird
chemicals or dust with my nose since I
believe bookers are there to catch
particles to prevent it from getting in
your lungs.
But sometimes I'll still even do it then
there's not much of a taste to booger if
I'm being honest or at least not that I
can describe.
There are different textures though.
Mainly how hard and soft there and some
are more juicy.
You're probably sick and disgusting now,
but as I am,
there you go.
There's not much more to it.
Thank you.
Keep it up.
Proud of you,
mark.
Well,
first of all,
I applaud you for your brave,
your bravery and your honesty and
sharing this anecdote because it's
important to know that they are out
there and it's important and it's nice
to get in your mind and kind of see.
I love some of the little details of
like,
sometimes if I'm around chemicals I'll
not eat my boogers,
but sometimes I'll still eat them or
like I'll hide it from my girlfriend,
but I fucking hate buggers off as snarly
did.
Well actually,
um,
I'm not going to shame my booger eating,
you know,
friends and family members out there or
whatever,
you know,
I smell off fargo my hand and smell it
so like I have never do it.
And you'll have never farted on your
hand and smelled it.
You always say it as a joke because they
actually do it.
I have done it.
I mean,
I don't,
it's not something I regularly do,
but I've done it.
Okay.
Do you not farted on your house?
Smelled it?
Why hasn't anyone back there farther on
their hand and smelled it?
No,
they had shut out.
Fucking say it like that because it's
because it smells deck bro.
And I know you fargo on your hand and
smell it and we'll know you ran to the
bathroom.
No,
again,
he's doing it right now,
Zack.
Of course Moses.
Oh,
of course.
Thank you Zach.
The one honest guy,
of course.
How can you not?
Thank you Zach.
Your honesty,
your fresh of breath.
Shitter.
I don't believe that.
Sheeko have you farted on your hands?
Smelled it.
He's he's on a call.
Oh,
okay.
You don't believe Zach?
Why would not lie about that?
No,
no.
Zach,
are you being truthful?
I swear to God.
I believe him.
This is a familiar,
it's a guide.
I don't believe you.
Frankly.
I didn't.
I don't,
I don't get,
why would you need to do that?
What's the motivation?
Cause you want,
but you're going to know that's right.
Stronger cause a stronger smell.
I don't factor in it too.
I haven't done it in a while,
but to sit here and tell me you've never
butter if copped yourself fucking
outrage and ally far and you buttercup,
it never done it.
Buy It.
And what else have you lied to me about?
Um,
about this guy who eats his boogers?
Incidentally,
a serendipitously,
I saw this article that eating buggers
may boost in unity.
So there is a biological explanation for
all you people who are shoveling buggers
into your mouth.
Eating boogers may boost immunity.
Scientist suspect.
I'm not going to bother to read it,
but you get the idea.
You're looking at this little booger
picker.
I mean all that means is that they're
full of germs and you're just eating
germs right?
There you go.
Cool.
Exactly.
Den.
Yeah,
so eat your boogers.
It's good for you.
From Ben.
Hello,
Ethan and Eli was listening on podcast
88 and you all brought up the idea of
enjoying the act of smelling your own
farts.
I would like to weigh in on this debate
and that you know that I'm with Ethan on
this one.
I was against him on his wiping
technique,
but this is common ground.
Thank you.
I'm glad we found some common ground.
Then I like,
I think the liking,
smelling I liking your own farm is a
biological thing because animals
naturally try to smell their own
territory.
So your own bodily smells will smell
better you than they would have someone
else's because it indicates it's not
their territory.
I think that enjoying your farts is
totally normal and human nature.
I would even go as far as to say that
most of us hotbox our cars with farts
and secretly enjoy it.
I don't,
he goes on to say you are my favorite
content creators on Youtube and Papa
Blas.
Thank you.
So thank you ben for corroborating.
What I've always said is that isla is a
liar.
Prolific Liar.
In fact,
um,
is sheeko still on the phone?
Yeah.
Could to see.
Can you ask him just,
I want to know if he's farts on his hand
and smells it.
Do you think he does?
Do you find on your own hand and smell
it?
Ethan wants to know.
Never ever.
He says shaking his head because their
lives are reasonable person.
Give me a break.
I think it's a 50 50 kind of thing.
I think it's a front.
Let's do a poll and do a poll.
Alright,
here we go first.
Well to it.
Okay.
Should we say,
and that's a lot.
Should we say?
Do you like the smell of your own farts
or no.
While you're talking is very different
to during the school cause you admit to
liking the smell of your own farm?
No.
It's you tolerate the smell of your own
farm?
No,
I still think it smells like farts.
Wait,
Whoa,
wait,
wait.
Let's see.
I'm willing to go as far as to say that,
that my own farts don't smell as bad to
me as they probably do to other people.
I'll go that far.
It does pull down.
When you fart you,
it bothers you the smell of your own
farm.
No,
I'll agree with what Dan said.
It's not as gross tolerable,
so it's tolerable to you as tall,
but that doesn't mean I go out of my way
to fucking scoop it up and my,
if you're sitting and watching TV and
you rip a fat one,
you're not going to get up and leave the
room.
No.
You'll bask in it,
but I'm not going to enjoy it.
You're not going to breathe deep or
anything.
Do you hold your nose?
Do you avoid breathing?
No.
You don't go out of your way to avoid
it.
So you breathe it and do not think about
the smell at all.
Do you like think like,
oh,
that was a fucking,
that was a pretty gnarly one,
or that one wasn't that bad.
No,
I do think.
Okay,
so you're analyzing,
you're smelling it.
You are smelling your own car or,
so what are the,
the options are you don't like your own
part at all,
tolerate it?
No,
no,
no.
Let's just say,
have you ever farted on your hand and
smelled it?
Yes or no?
That's the one.
Uh,
and your whole life,
I mean,
you know,
as a kid your whole life,
have you ever once in your life now or
ever before?
Just yes or no.
All right,
and I'm setting it to run through the
weekend so we can get a nice sample
size.
You update us?
No,
I'm not waiting until Monday.
All right.
Pulls up everybody.
Let's go finally from Alfredo.
Alfredo never betray the family.
Hey Anthony,
first of all,
great to see you guys doing better
recently.
Hope you guys keep up the great
momentum,
but now enough of the funny business.
Well I don't think that was very fun at
all.
This is serious shit.
I year ago I being a lazy ass thick boy
chose to sit down and pee in my toilet.
Since then,
it's been my preferred method of
urination.
Recently I saw Messi come forward and
mentioned that he does it as well.
This gave me the courage to mention this
among my friends.
They all ridiculed me and made me even
question my decision.
This is a guy related question.
I'll leave it to us guys.
Sorry.
Yellow.
Um,
is it weird to pee sitting down?
Well again,
I'm not,
I don't want to shame my fellow,
my fellow boys here.
If you eat your boogers,
if you pee sitting down,
that's a kind of a beautiful testament
to how diverse we as human beings really
are.
Some of us far on their own hands and
smell it,
which is,
as I understand it,
very normal and courteous.
[inaudible].
Let me check on that.
Um,
I don't think it's weird at all.
I know a lot of guys that pee sitting
down.
Personally,
I don't like it because I feel that I
can't squeeze out as much liquid as when
I'm standing up because a lot of times
if I'm taking a shit,
what do you see?
La English shocked.
What did that fuck?
Do you see?
What do you see?
You look 55% yes,
it's early.
It's early.
We need more 733 votes.
It's not enough.
It's not a big enough sample size.
Not a big enough sample size.
That is a statistically viable.
No.
Yes it is 700 that will change maybe 5%
really fast.
Well,
that will 5% at most from now and either
direction.
That's what I'm telling you.
All went down.
It went down.
This is why I gave it three days.
We,
we need thousands of responses.
Reaming and a cloud of Fart.
You guys are the weird,
you guys are the weird ones.
When you scratch your balls,
do you smell your hand?
Oh yeah,
of course.
No.
Why?
Why would you?
Because it's the same thing.
You want to know what's going on there?
What am I crazy?
How smelly or your balls really has a
sense.
There's nothing to smell.
Sometimes there's a little Bob,
a good new smells plan or not your
balls,
but like your region,
like you're fucking region.
Especially shampoos.
Gibbs.
It's your man musk.
Zach,
do you smell your hand after you scratch
this dude?
Zach's on a fucking liar.
He's not ashamed to,
yeah,
you're all lying.
You love your man Musk.
That's what it is.
Thank you.
Sacral though man.
Musk is not a phrase that they're 10
they're really happy to get behind,
but I appreciate what you're saying.
You know like the area between like your
thighs.
You know that that's what I'm talking
about.
He loves it.
I love it.
All right me say it's not over.
It's just beginning and you make sure
that,
what are we at right now?
What's the percentage?
It's 54 46 was changing so much.
Give me a break.
Listen,
what we're doing here is important.
East stigmatizing.
We are getting out in the open that we
are beautiful,
diverse creatures.
Some of us piece sitting down,
some of us eat our own bookers and some
of us far in our hands and smell it.
Okay and can still be gross?
Nope.
That will cannot be.
I'm just saying we're out there and
maybe we maybe,
maybe it'd be nice Ila to not feel
ashamed of myself all the time.
You know?
Oh I took a piece of shit at the toilet
and smelled it big fucking whoop that
you do that right?
I think it's interesting that 55% of the
people for the 53 Ooh,
people are goofing on me.
If anything you guys just be honest on
this poll but either way you said 10% so
I don't give a fuck what it drops.
You just got coby don this,
this,
this sample to this is the live
audience.
We got to wait for the vod audience.
Still Rolling.
Cut from a different cloth.
How many people have voted now a seven
you're going to tell me that's not a
significant sample size.
1700 people.
Give me a break cause her walking.
You guys think you're so special.
You don't fart on you smell it.
So Bourgeois,
yes,
US peasants fart on our hands and
smelling it.
Oh look at you.
You'll that's right.
That's right.
My name now the Alabama to people that
don't fart on the hand.
It's smell it.
I can't do an impression.
That's all I've got here today.
So I think we covered a lot of ground.
I think we learned a lot.
And um,
I want everyone to be very comfortable
and ha.
Let's take a call for Chris Sake.
I didn't take a call today.
Pizza Guy.
Vape nation wants to talk about kids
vaping.
Do you want a boy or a girl has an
answer or how does the king,
his ass has an answer.
Are you serious about the King Taylor?
You are on the air.
Tell me,
do you know about if kings,
how king's wiped their ass or are you,
are you fucking with me?
Taylor Taylor is it drops you have to
unmute or something or maybe no,
no,
he's alive.
Hmm.
Alright Taylor.
God bless you.
Appreciate you.
That you're the rest.
It's worth a shot.
You're the greatest that ever did it.
Um,
what else do we got?
Is the air he is at the air force.
Oh yeah.
Fuck this guy.
Oh,
these are all terminated.
Okay.
Screening Room.
I'm trying to understand this.
Let's talk to Andrew.
He's a high ranking air force official.
I don't know what he has to say.
Andrea,
are you there?
No.
Okay.
Well this is a hip guys.
We are killing it today on these calls.
One 801 eight.
Oh eight hut mean.
Let's just get a call.
Uh,
do you want,
this guy has a similar pizza experience.
They've nation fan talks about kids
vaping or do you want a boy or a girl?
I don't know.
I'm not compelled.
MMM,
okay.
Just move on.
No,
no,
no.
Let's stop with Scotty.
Scotty,
you're on there.
Why isn't sound working?
I guess it's not working.
Yeah,
it sounds like something's not working.
Okay.
Uh,
Harrison,
you are on the air.
Harrison.
Just keep going.
This is great.
Yeah.
I'm trying.
I know this is a mate.
This is a compelling stuff.
Harrison talked to me for Christ's sake.
The fuck is going on.
Well,
are you sure it's working?
I think it's obviously not.
Well the do didn't want to come and look
at it.
Oh,
you want to just prolong this?
I was just going to ask them if they
fire in their hand or not.
I didn't care about anything that I just
want to know about their habits in the
bathroom.
Then I think let's just,
okay,
let's wrap this baby up guys.
All to all my fellow hand farting.
Want me to tell you what we know?
You know what I liked the most about
people that far in the hand and smell
dealer.
It's not 52% still.
You Act like that's a victory for you.
I'm just saying it's going down.
You know what I like about people at
[inaudible]?
They are courageous and they are
truthful.
Yeah.
I find it hard to believe that people
don't like the smell of their own farts.
It's like,
but you're saying it like you enjoy it.
I do.
I enjoy it and it was so wild and what's
hard to believe?
It's the gross smell because it's like
biological,
I feel like you almost cannot deny it.
Cause if you're willing to sit there and
analyze the smell of your own heart,
which you admit to doing,
and a sense you couldn't do that without
enjoying you put in and Jay,
you couldn't do that without going good.
Right?
No.
You're not making any sense.
Why?
I'm not analyzing,
I'm just sitting there and thinking like
people.
Do you think all the time you're
thinking yourself,
what kind of far does that,
if you could just take a smell.
Oh,
it's like,
oh this is really growth.
Or Oh this is not that bad.
You know?
It's just taught.
I like when it's grocer.
Okay.
Like a diarrhea fart.
You're like,
damn,
that shit is foul,
but it's good.
I don't know what,
are you kidding?
I'm not kidding.
I'm being real with you right now.
I Dunno.
My grossing you out.
Well,
I think it's gross.
Yeah,
I think I thought that was the,
most people think that fart smell
amazing now that over 50% say they fired
on the end of the smell.
It like that's kind of an interesting
revelation,
right?
It is.
So there you go.
We met,
we're uncovering things here on the
issue podcast where this is so off the
rails.
We've got to end the,
yeah,
let's end it.
All right.
Um,
off the rails guys have a blessed that
weekend.
Okay.
Hope you all enjoyed here with those
today on the HD pod castle life.
I thank you all so much for joining us.
I am so excited for the weekend.
I hope y'all have a great,
terrific weekend silk cited.
Um,
anything else going on?
Not really.
Oh really?
So we will see,
oh next week we have a Tom Sikora and
Christina p,
two of my favorite people on a Thursday.
It's Wednesday cause I thought we were
going to Disney on Friday,
Thursday.
Oh,
okay.
So they're coming on Wednesday at the
usual time.
And then the day after that,
I'm so excited.
I'm taking the whole family to
Disneyland.
We are cause for some reason all of our
family member's birthday is in the same
season.
It's all in the fall.
So we're doing a client family bonanza.
There's 10 of us going together.
It's going to be fricking awesome.
So if you were in Disneyland,
are you sure it's on Thursday?
I thought I looked on the calendar.
The end of this podcast is so off the
rails.
I'm just looking at my fucking calendar.
No,
hang on guys.
Now this is important.
Disneyland on the 25th Oh yeah,
that is Thursday.
So if you're a Disney on Thursday,
come say what up?
We're going to be wearing orange beanies
and looking like a bunch of clowns and
Isla is going to make a shirt,
a custom shirt for everyone.
It says clan family birthday bonanza
2018 can you have a picture of me
farting like and that rain cloud and
then trailing my hand up to my nose.
No.
Okay.
Isla was going to have a talk and I mean
she was going to prohibit me from smart
smelling farts.
Are we off the rails?
Dan?
I think we're off the rails.
Yeah,
let's end it guys.
Thank you all so very much.
Have a nice weekend.
Oh,
watch.
Go.
Uh Oh his arc.
I'll keep saying go.
Sorry.
Watch ozark.
That shows fucking awesome.
I'm going to run home and watch the
season finale of season two.
Huge fan of that show and Tlc,
by the way,
walking my huge wife,
that one's the best one.
Her Vagina is so wide that her husband's
swims,
swims.
When they have sex,
he swims in her vagina off the rails.
Right.
All right,
and it,
Dan just ended it by.